in the summer of 1944 Colonel Claus von
Stauffenberg is a brilliant young
officer with a distinguished war record
he's an early supporter of the Nazi
movement but news of the regime's
brutality convinces him that cannon must
be eliminated
July 20th 1944 Stauffenberg is summoned
to a conference at the Wolf's Lair
Hitler's remote military headquarters in
East Prussia this is where Stauffenberg
will make the forty first attempt to
kill Hitler
will flare is a two square mile compound
divided into three nested security zones
each with its own checkpoints and
razor-wire fences the outer perimeter is
ring with minefields machine-gun nests
and anti-aircraft guns the tightly
controlled inner circle where Hitler
resides holds an assortment of
outbuildings and massive concrete
bunkers the walls of Hitler's personal
bunker are more than 16 and a half feet
thick
he clearly feels very very safe that
Hitler's sense of security will prove to
be false
Stalin bird manages to smuggle - 1
kilogram slabs of plastic explosives
into the compound the security at the
Wolf's Lair is astounding now it's
focused on several specific threats air
attack and airborne assault raids as
good as layered as the security is it is
not proof against someone attacking from
inside Hitler's inner circle if they are
trusted if they can get a weapon into
proximity with Hitler inside the inner
defense zone then yes they have a shot
at taking him around
moments before his meeting with Hitler
Dauphin Bergen is aimed at armed the
first brand of explosives and hide it in
a briefcase before they're able to fuse
the second bomb there's a knock door
burg is ordered to the briefing room
immediately and grabs the briefcase and
heads out the door leaving behind the
second brick of explosives the time
pencils that lunch Dauphin burg used
technically were 30-minute devices the
problem is it was a hot day it was a
humid day and these are things that tend
to speed that up he was walking around
with a live time bomb that could go off
any time which donphan burg enters the
room the meeting is already underway he
takes a position near Hitler it places
the briefcase on the floor moments later
he excuses himself from the room as the
meeting continues a 1 kilogram bomb sits
a mere three feet from the Fuhrer
only seconds remain on the fuse
[Music]
as the smoke clears Stauffenberg is
headed to Berlin to help manage the
transition of government
he had watched the explosion from a
short distance away and he was of the
conviction that no one in the room could
have survived
the blast blows out windows part of a
wall and buckle floor the conference
table is shattered and the plaster
ceiling comes crashing down
of the 20-plus men in the room for a
fatal man but Hitler himself emerges
with relatively minor injuries
subsequently he begins to see a survival
as further evidence of the intervention
of Providence as he explains to his
doctor he says I am immortal
I am invulnerable